Hilary Clinton has a memoir coming out
soon it's called what happened it
includes quite a bit of material about
the 2016 election hence the title what
happened
we have excerpts and to me the
simultaneously funniest
and saddest and most frustrating parts
of it are some of what Hillary Clinton
believes happened in 2016 let's put up a
screenshot here where Hillary Clinton
writes throughout the primaries every
time I wanted to hit back against
Bernie's attacks I was told to restrain
myself noting that his plans didn't add
up
that they would inevitably mean raising
taxes on middle-class families or that
they were little more than a pipe dream
all of this could be used to reinforce
his argument that I wasn't a true
progressive my team kept reminding me
that we didn't want to alienate Bernie
supporters President Obama urged me to
grit my teeth and lay off Bernie as much
as I could I felt like I was in a
straitjacket this is like full full full
victim mode blame everybody mode except
for herself consider she's blaming her
team for telling her to restrain herself
Bernie for over-promising things
according to her Bernie supporters sort
of as being part of that idea that they
would in correctly identify Hillary
Clinton is not progressive if she
criticized Bernie's plans if you can't
figure out how to navigate like forget
the victim blit that the victim and
blaming everybody stuff for a second if
you can't figure out how to successfully
navigate those hurdles in a primary have
you really earned the presidency then
you don't deserve to win and I mean you
look at Hillary Clinton she had every
single advantage on her side she had the
mainstream media and support of her she
had a Democratic Party behind her from
the beginning coordinated her as the
candidate from the get-go
ENC I mean there was just a number of
examples should name recognition she had
been through the process before with her
own campaigns with her husband's
campaigns I mean it was her fault for
losing but Pat if it wasn't for her
staff as well as Bernie supporters and
Bernie doing things that were
restraining or constraining her then she
wouldn't have had a problem it was
almost like Bernie Sanders was trying to
win the presidency himself it's crazy
it's almost like yeah Bernie was doing
what he
that would help him win here's another
quote okay from hillary clinton's
upcoming book and it just gets even
crazier when I finally challenged Bernie
during a debate to name a single time I
changed a position or a vote because of
a financial contribution he couldn't
come up with anything nonetheless his
attacks caused lasting damage making it
harder to unify progressives in the
general election and paving the way for
Trump's crooked Hillary campaign do you
understand what she's saying she's
saying
Bernie's attacks against her during the
primary ultimately made her lose to
Donald Trump now it's true 12% of Bernie
primary supporters voted for Trump and
every single one of them I would like to
talk to you and figure out what the hell
they were thinking and mathematically
you can look at that and say well look
at how close some of these states were
it could have actually flipped it to
Hillary Clinton that's different and we
could make that argument with Jill Stein
in some states that is a different
argument than saying the sole reason
that in the grand scheme of her entire
campaign and Bernie's entire campaign
and the eventual primary a rather
national campaign between Hillary
Clinton and Trump the fact that Bernie
criticized her during the primary is why
she ultimately lost to Donald Trump and
there was a number of topics where
Bernie Sanders would lay off of her like
he had the golden opportunity to go
after her emails and he said he doesn't
give a damn about her Damn emails that
the sort of lack of depth and nuance in
these analyses that I've read from
Hillary Clinton's upcoming book when it
comes to Bernie's big promises the big
picture she's missing is that Bernie's
appeal wasn't limited to or even mostly
because of his specific policy proposals
which by the way in some areas differed
from Hillary Clinton's proposals in
other areas overlapped quite a bit with
Hillary Clinton's proposals not not
nearly in all areas
Bernie's approach is what was mostly
different it didn't come off as
calculated in the way that Hillary
Clinton's approach did Bernie was
willing to speak way more toughly about
Republicans early on he was much more
willing to criticize the system at large
in a real and sort of genuine seeming
way as more than just
there are symptoms that Hillary Clinton
pointed to about our system that aren't
so good the reality is if it were all
policy that was the result of how the
primary and eventually the national
election took place Bernie would not
have done as well as he did I was one of
the first people to say you know
particularly on foreign policy Bernie's
not really as fleshed out as Hillary
Clinton is remember when he was asked
something about Russia or Putin I
believe during one of the debates he
seemed stunned like he had just been
sucker-punched write me that he really
lacked some preparedness on those issues
the point is you felt like Bernie
genuinely supported his proposals and
believed in them
whereas Hillary Clinton thought a lot of
her proposals were good politics and
would poll well but would do something
totally different if it's what boaters
preferred and this was a 500 page book
that Hillary Clinton just released I
really wonder if there's any
self-reflection in there and she doesn't
even have to go into the specifics of
maybe people thought she was too closely
tied to Wall Street of the big banks but
maybe just you know an understanding of
why people thought she was dishonest or
just didn't like her at a visceral level
I think she misses it I I think she just
doesn't get it she still doesn't get
that the Bernie candidacy was not what
she thinks it was she doesn't get that
Bernie's ideas weren't reactive right
Bernie
even without the fully formed foreign
policy ideas that I've criticized Bernie
Sanders for his proposals were always
part of the broader politics that he's
been doing for decades not force not
concocted to appeal specifically in
November of 2016 to voters so I think
Hillary Clinton is way off the mark here
assuming that the book is her honest
thoughts it's also possible that she's
written the book in this way continuing
to politically posture for one reason or
another I look forward to reading it not
because I think it's gonna be a great
read but because I really want to
understand the full misunderstanding
that Hillary Clinton might have about
what the hell happened back in November
it's obviously an opportunity for her to
make money but some people are looking
at this as a you know a way to set
herself up from another run you need to
go again for 2020 I think she'll get to
feed it again III don't even in the
Democratic primary I don't think it's a
good idea and I hope that's not what it
is but
I've been getting some tweets about that
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman send me your
thoughts we'll be back after this
today's program is made possible by taga
dabbe the hosting specialists offering a
range of flexible hosting packages
including dedicated VPS and cloud server
options as well as custom server
solutions and uk-based colocation
services for your business or project
taga Dabbs web hosting services support
a wide range of customers and businesses
worldwide including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more and taga dab has a
really user-friendly interface so you
don't have to worry about being super
tech savvy they can automate almost
everything you need for total ease of
use they are really proud of their team
of expert hosting specialists who are
also their support team 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is currently offering our
viewers and listeners a twenty british
pound free credit about twenty four US
dollars to all customers signing up to
give you a chance to try the service
this is a limited availability offer
first-come first-served for viewers and
listeners of the David Pakman show to
take advantage of it go to signup tag a
DAB comm /td PS and use the offer code
TDPS 20 all one word all lowercase
during account registration